- Fresh-pressed, Crazy Fresh for dress.
(funky upbeat music)
- I originally saw "1917"
which I think is an incredible film,
"Knives Out" I really loved as well.
I'm trying to go through all the list
of the last things I've,
I've seen so many films
in the last two weeks,
"Uncut Gems."
- "Hustlers" was probably one of the best.
- I love "Uncut Gems," I love it.
- Love "Jojo Rabbit."
- "The Farewell" I love,
obviously, obviously, obviously.
I dug "Dolemite" a lot,
"Uncut Gems" is like,
you know, those are my boys.
(speaking in a foreign language)
- "Parasite."
- "Parasite," yes.
- Director Bong, "Parasite's" amazing.
- "Parasite," you didn't even
have to finish the question.
- I think I went in
thinking it was going to be
an actual little worm type of parasite,
so boy was I surprised.
- I haven't seen "Little Women" yet,
so I'm dying to see that.
- I wanna see "Jojo
Rabbit," "Marriage Story,"
I'm very excited.
- I've still not seen the
second season of "Fleabag,"
I've got to catch up.
- Well I don't want to say
too much about other films,
in case people vote
for them instead of me.
(funky upbeat music)
- I'm really keen to meet myself.
(speaking in a foreign language)
(laughs)
- I'm excited just to be here,
to be part of this again.
- I've never met Brad Pitt.
- Freaking out.
Hamm, Reese Witherspoon, Queen B,
you know what I mean?
Tom Hanks is my celebrity crush.
- I love Tom Hanks' films.
- Tom Hanks, I mean, not
to cheer for the home team,
but what a great night to
be here with "Toy Story 4",
and have him up for such
an incredible award.
- Oh I wanna see Ricky Gervais.
- I seen everybody, I saw
Olivia Cole went on the carpet,
I didn't realize she was back this year,
but it's 'cause of "The Crown".
Phoebe Waller-Bridge, it's just
like everything, everything.
I just passed Eddie on
the carpet, Mr Murphy,
so that was pretty dope.
- You know, I'm excited
to see all my cast mates,
because I haven't really seen
anybody, you know, this year.
I'm excited for Reese and
Jen, obviously, as nominees.
- Both of our leads are
up against each other,
together, with each other,
that's very exciting.
- Who am I excited to see?
You know, what I am really excited about
is sitting down with Adam
and Scarlett and Laura,
and having all of us at
the same table together,
celebrating our movie.
- I love Nora, Awkwafina,
in "The Farewell,"
and "Knives Out" and
"Chernobyl" and "Parasite,"
so I'm excited.
- I don't know, Ellen
DeGeneres, I just saw her,
J.Lo's approaching the building,
I heard whispers of it.
I'm just, everyone's coming
tonight and it's crazy,
it's, I'm really excited.
(musical chord)